une grande partie de la famille
socialiste s'étaient donné rendez-vous à
jarnac pour commémorer le 10e
anniversaire de la mort de françois
mitterrand
un hommage officiel dans la ville natale
de l'ancien président où il est enterré
dans le caveau familial j'évite imbert
sur place et josée blais sexe demande la
minute de silence de recueillement
devant le caveau familial laurent fabius
et lionel jospin entourant mazarine la
fille de françois mitterrand
et puis jack lang roland dumas que l'on
voyait plus guère avec ses camarades
socialistes tant d'autres la photo de
famille est rare chez sur le lieu qui
nous rassemble beaucoup de socialistes
de ma génération c'est elle qui peut les
papas de remplacement et s'ils ne sont
pas tous ces enfants chacun a semblé
aujourd'hui revendiquer une petite part
mines héritage jusqu'à la façon comme
les anciens ministres hubert védrine
louis mexandeau de porter le chapeau
comme mitterrand un rayonnement par mail
aujourd'hui mais demain tout le monde
mais moi mais entre tous la star
incontestée du jour c'est elle mazarine
pingeot dans le cimetière sous les
photographes sont à l'affût un peu plus
loin
elles affirment ressentir aujourd'hui la
vraie réhabilitation de son père
elle était bien remplie de fierté encore
quand avec gilbert le fils cadet de
mitterrand elles dévoilent la plaque
commémorative sur la maison natale
mitterrand suscite décidément les
communismes politique même jean pierre
raffarin qui présidait la région quand
la maison a été rachetée à bluette ma
charentais et donc on peut discuter à sa
politique élevé aussi honorer sa mémoire
à l'intérieur le salon la salle à manger
qui virent grandir le futur chef de
l'état et en croisant les visiteurs du
jour encore des retrouvailles avec des
figures de toutes les époques de
mitterrand et de la gauche dans les
années qui ont aidé et exaltante
remarquable magnifique
voilà qu'on regarde un peu c'est dix ans
montrant suivi durant
beaucoup d'image de l'homme vivant que
je garde à l'esprit au club seuls deux
présidentiables du ps se sont fait
excuser aujourd'hui dominique strauss
kahn et ségolène royal parti soutenir la
candidate de gauche au chili lundi ce
bouquet puis l'autre témoin du défilé
les habitants de jarnac auront vu
presque autant de monde qu'il y a dix
ans